time much as I'm real fond oh well then
go for Guinea the trading is profitable
whether whether attempt although the
class the weather the climate we time
marches on
Egon was murdered for money Anderson was
murdered because he discovered Egon
secret Slayton was promised to get away
I'm taking stone and vomited it yeah
that's well for what snow they well
before you long before that you gotta
try the whole thing ties up call the
dealer girl it wins and loses the loot
Cloverdale and will hold their geyser
the whole thing hooks up over there a
girl who wins and loses the Lucky legs
contest local doctors our friend
surgical oh right hold it
quit tapping telephone wires spend your
time building up new rackets so the moon
flowering comes up for air you find it
doesn't morgue I'll go
getting a little made of them I didn't
try and take it over I took it over
you think we minded jecht why should you
I proven to you that I could run a
better than anyone else
Jenner isn't any good yes you you given
us a nice bit of revenue I given you
more than any four of them put together
and you are keep on doing it provided
you give me yeah you know what I mean
all this god damn look you can give this
to Sadie fryer Willie I can't you do
this time marches on wonderful stuff
mm-hmm
you know my mother wrote in the Flyleaf
to my MA my dad little Gabriel that
means huh no all right and remember you
may be only a big brother to me
oh god damn I punched up hey you think
you're clever don't you
you've been getting away from with not a
poem come down here and prove it who are
they did Kruger tell you no so I think
I'll keep one sitting right in the same
time much as I'm well what have you been
doing besides powdering your nose been
working on the first chapter of sin
doesn't pay the teen Leavenworth not
lately
say mr. Scott I've never she sure
well you told me I have a good time
while you were away
besides I don't see why it would hurt
you to play with Marty no no the idea is
I'm taking 845 New York good time much
as I'm mr. Bopp I don't know the next
line if there's anything you won't pay
me move what you like there did you like
beer without hearing go for walks and
and get that fine cool air on your chest
and go swimming in little pools and holy
Christ and where are mine what I'm
screwing about it green frills and fresh
air yeah we got real love it disappeared
yeah surprised hey what happened to her
well that's for you to tell us it's not
told you everything I know time much as
I'm Maryann didn't tell you anything you
were yourself we're in the courtyard god
damn it I headed up the best no I I
should have called but I was in the
neighborhood which is coming home from
the club and saw a nuts on the
neighborhood I know he's innocent will
you please try and help you of course
I'll be very glad to do anything I can
here we have a gasoline company bigger
than Standard Oil and all the oil
companies of the world combined the
stock Jesus Christ that's pure
unadulterated altruism and how do you
like that word
okay but don't ja the table I'm terribly
sensitive and right into the time
marches on you're playing Santa Claus
that's what you're doing playing Santa
Claus listen in a minute not ten days
ago I turned down a million dollars
profit on my 51% play me her goddamn
sucker
okay Mondragon all my life I know a
voice when I hear why am i sending the
best teacher in New York we split 50/50
to held it every day Santa Claus trying
to bring fame unfortunate young boys you
owe me a thing then they accept ready
money and I don't mean a thing that
goddamn thing am i I'm just fed up
moving around here well I hope you don't
think that I'm enjoying it
well it's just business if waiting
waiting waiting for something to happen
that's what burns me up and the fact
that I can remember the line burns me up
more that's your charm is it no time for
heroics they're out for blood
I'll just take my chin enough don't be
silly why should an innocent person take
it but you have a memory okay United
ingo what sir don't be afraid it's only
a little blood type O blood good
my gentle puck can I stop it again my
gentle puck take that transformed scalp
them off the head of that of my gentle
puck yeah my gentle puck take this
transformed scalp tumult the head of
this is sweety time much is on your
lonesome oh yeah Joe Wilson's within the
air to our cup yep alright we don't care
to waste time we accept and will
recommend your appointment at once will
you be ready to take charge
I will you louse you cut me out of a
lion where time marches on you know
shall I believe that your reputation
being at stake is one of the reasons why
father accept Oh nuts
sorry they're too yellow to face the
bigger problems of life they gotta fight
their way through with guns hold it for
a still smaller round she divorced him
married me she saw me oh yeah ready
alright you it's the graveyard of the
civilization that shot from under us the
world of outmoded ideas ha ha that's
very good
time marches on I tried to build eleven
go a love of wall
goddamnit I'm sorry this isn't my Betty
Oh
bedding damn it miss Nightingale you
can't stay here in this freezing cold
this won't kill me if anything kills me
it will be my anger again okay fire
so no
what that was the matter with him anyhow
uh sir no no what
thank you Robert yeah I don't know I'm
awfully sorry
god damn it must be wonderful to be a
newspaperman have such beautiful child
like god damn it
Virginia's in Russia and Russia doctor
Spiker is Daffy concentrate concentrate
hi your light concentration camp they
don't need to justify their lives I do
I'm a physician I'm a surgeon goddammit
sorry give the cue Oh Jim you shall go
leave here now
and no cost not money oh Jesus project
in which he states that the airlines are
join South American the United States
will be of immeasurable economic value
and intrinsic value or whatever the hell
you argue there are thousands just like
Philips honest decent self-respecting
men who've lost their jobs through no
fault of that moon god damn it let me
start light away again yeah I'm lucky
lucky say you want to be secondary yeah
yeah Chicago
you
oh damn it man you see they're down to
the last 12 bucks and I think it'd be my
little Isis oh good Jesus Christ what's
around
can't get shot this back and forth so on
and so on and so on
she starts crying more and more finally
she gets what a crazy way talking around
oh come on Peggy be a sport
the guy's an hour on for the dependent
on this point is guitar tonight yeah
yeah if you're the Mac coming listen
again you have half a mind all right can
I get like a baby
how will you say that I even I'm we're
way over here all right as we go back I
put Garson York I can go for me 20 years
ago instead of suddenly discus
governesses vertical but then the
assignment can someone up here right
away
yes it is
and just to keep the record straight
boys you might tell your palpitating
readers at the first subscription on the
list and the one myth 1 million very
tight wait a minute maybe he's got
something there one good night's haul
out of this and we can all go home I'll
be a singer
wow you will be in charge of the wagon
train leaving in the morning see that
all necessary supplies are pull up to
tell ok good yeah 10:11 break once more
come on alright great
yeah send lamebrain in here look you can
stay here your clothes dry out but you
better be off or on your way aren't that
very soon because I Alameda will send us
wind and weather position changes and
chips and thunder thing now so to help
you get yourself back in the marine mood
I'm restricting you to quarters for
tended son ship right now I bet he's the
he-man boss have there heard that I work
with Devils all the level yeah sorry
you see we the Rangers have been trying
to get something on judge Blake for
months dammit any honks there's my
partner judge caught it Jeff surely
you're mistaken
I'm lieutenant Colton the union officers
temporarily assigned a secret service in
hopes that we would might be able to get
rid of this thing we shot well smoke oh
boy looks like our Luck's still whole
I can't raise my hands off the ground
imitation birds and beasts the forests
to violent ago sorry no oh let's go
ahead just do some more paper figuring
you're one of these destructive critics
is everything a guy who does dog chuck
was on the point of exposing Marsha
unless she cleared up so so my heart's
best affections and all my worldly goods
I thee endow
join your right hands again
so why should this Oh God let's pick it
up I thought you promised not to lecture
but I'm stuck I was there enough light
in the alley for you to see the
defendant very clearly I could see
pretty clearly yet enough to swear to
them Jacobs God it won't come take a tip
from the family position now damn I
can't remember that damn it what's to be
done
all right I'll give you radio well
produce the gas did this blow out from
1930
hmm what about that coat it's a bad fit
bad fit that's it yeah - tight on the
arm not undermine that's my coat yeah my
hat what's it doing on me well they do
me give me that go away you're gonna be
a hell of a story getting this Tora
alright
you must be the first one to taste it
thank you bye Daniel about the happiness
taking experiment to prepare for you my
most famous dish chicken ala running you
must be famous it isn't everybody can
have a good people on the inside of this
tent you will see it on firing an
inspiration of their words no no no no
but that one no that one no that will no
rice which is a I poured it down the
face oh I meant it for dr. Harrigan I
wouldn't have stopped oh that's an idea
but it's true Monsieur
the whole all literature let me try it
again for goodness sake oh I thought a
job have enough oh yes you have a job
yeah you're entitled to 10% but I've got
a job haven't I
yes I think your head yeah you're
entitled to 10% sales good oh damn
do you suppose he rides in the park
everyday with seven that line was screw
it and I just heard from the friend in
Washington after ah four years I dreamed
of this moment this shall be the
creation of everything I don't know what
I've done
hello hello I'm sorry oh damn it over
you see the airplane would you grow up
all right let's go people be arriving in
a minute the main thing is I kind of owe
mrs. Harvey I'm our last Sonny Boy EE D
so sue well that's a shame my husband
will be so sorry to miss you ah really
this is very a very man you see mrs.
Cleary you will get behind him in the
armor behind you mrs. Mason will get
behind him me or something oh my life
hasn't been so pleasantly and even
though I know you put that over words
this is the worst I wanted I would have
ended up oh god damn it
right in this lesson you'll find a
typewriter there is everything you need
Oh may I respectfully that your honor it
is your oh not my legs pretty Rogers
must be all right
nothing freyal let's waste no more time
we take the shortcut across the street
Kayal old god damn it my accent give me
back my mutton toe nuts got it dude you
bought your rotten little Prince Ferg
Arabic and when he ceased to be a
reigning prince you had to buy a thief
realizing a sinister influence was tying
the hands of the police I began a
personal in Oh nuts a personal one
where's Annie he's over the 7/11 Club
working on a story that's for a rock
this town tell him to stick the rocking
babies that's what he get what is old a
little ah well that goddamn thing locked
again
hey listen chief did you think you can
spare me I guess me and the boys would
be getting back the parade we probably
have to run foot race now those miss
Blaine brought aboard ship are still in
our room
mr. dance Curtis reported to me and I've
had the ship searched we found a rope
attached to the boat deck rail they must
have lured themselves to the dock mr. go
torturous things are still in a cabin
she's a chance
that I never was
I'm always bad luck to me kind of a
[ __ ]
I know Dolph will say cut it it's good
to see you too Sara Lance don't need no
time I'm gonna keys I'm not fooling
besides I don't know what the hell to
say come on line up it's the Lord Tory
the hell it is the law yes there's the
law oh yeah if we could get a line
little Macy's outfit might lead us to
higher ups that's what the chief wants
yes god damn it I don't know what I'm
supposed to say doesn't need explaining
okay it doesn't need explaining I forgot
the goddamn line looks like Heppner
might have something about this kebab so
we return the Scofield to kit I'll be
I'm gonna pick it up
you're funny
oddly
okay well check the passenger list of
all planes leaving the Metro fella Oh
God
I see so you don't know anything at all
about house number break beautiful now
wants to put you out of business doesn't
he it's obvious there isn't enough God I
don't know the hell I'm talking about
I'm sure they're out of commission I
laid off the mechanics to some goddamn
reason I don't know boy
agent jet we're happy at this time to
present-- a warner brothers first
Oh what the hell ladies and gentlemen
we're happy at this time to present a
Warner Brothers Oh nuts
mm absolutely making some seven curtain
calls on the basement on the stage the
farewell to Toscanini our balls you make
me so mad what have I done well with the
whole underworld having just as much
reason for wanting to pin the murder Oh
nuts how did you ins know you honorably
wanted her to take us with Williams you
haven't nut do I do that oh how long do
you how much both nuts how can I have by
telling me what you know about this
Gilbert case Oh sergeant oh oh oh
torchy will you cut it out Dibble kill
the guy and that's that if what had been
killed with a tire wrench there might be
some reason to suspect a garage helper
well what in the name of nuts if board
had been killed with a tire wrench there
might have been some reason to suspect a
garage helper but what in the name of
Pete would this kid be doing with a
hypodermic needle load of a pressed acid
five for one I owe that sign five
thousands basket on I don't know but it
wasn't decking a different season oh
Jesus shut up the deer did eat it you
bastard why don't you say it cut it's
like a fairy tale
here's to the very halls of Montezuma
cuz I can't move my head because if I do
I'm tired god damn witch come on folks
I'm I'm much obliged to you for bringing
me here tonight I felt a little scared
and and blue when I first came here but
I don't feel that way now because of
everything but please don't ask me to
sing again mMmmm
oh Jesus I must have a line someplace oh
yeah I don't bother with love hem the
time you great men are also hard well I
have to be hard yes I suppose you do
there's so many girls would be after you
because you earn so much money Nestle
famous boy that's just what miss day
said she would is she's just the type
you have to watch out for
you don't mean miss day oh my dear
didn't you see how furious she was when
I stepped in tonight his boiler plans
oh god I am better liner heaven you know
I've always had sort of a little dream
electrical shock just like a dream girl
well anyway lots of people have dream
girls but dream electrician lasats god
damn Rima don't know if you're not a
[ __ ] okay [ __ ] uh-oh
Betty mama Oh why didn't you tell me
can I go with you Commissioner I risk
that can I go with you and they've got
the gang on can I go [ __ ] together they
entered the Trask home shortly after
Strickland paid over the money and while
Strickland stood guard with a gun in his
hand
the accomplice opened the safe extracted
the $20,000 but before they could escape
however my coat isn't open God
well I'm sorry gentlemen but I'm afraid
I'll have to report this but well
gentlemen I'm sorry but I'm praying I to
report this - hey ah I'm sorry gentlemen
but duty calls i'm prego have to report
this becoming that this ramp Papa won't
like it
what do you think about this a little
bit of unfair to have a better collector
hey don't you my book is completely
rational enough definite scientific
value you're positive about the house I
am do anything to me god damn it
hey yes there's a Chinese chop I'm at
the heavens which predicts events just
like the horse go that oh Jesus when I
give orders around here they take them
from me and nobody else incidentally is
your wrecker the girl the one lovely
there isn't that stray yeah I think any
little help there yes
looks like you've been on in a shopping
spree yeah I have that's a man hey are
ya good money but I'm preparing for Law
School what up you ever hear of night
school did you ever hear of boys working
to help them others a mother like yours
one of the finest women that ever bore a
thoroughbred and free no-good sons of
[ __ ] I tell you man
sometimes it's enough to put me up in my
lines the Jesus shut up the didn't dig
it
it bit me cut it out Kenny you're here
to get hurt I'm being your little boy
after sighs I'm longer on the ears for
ya okay okay
Jesus Christ but anything that you say
henceforth may be used against you at
your own trial but you can't arrest him
he yeah I thought he could do it it got
there
now listen to me you can't do that to me
you're crucifying me you can't get away
with it let's do it again
god damn it moves seven mil under Sun
let's reload it sometime you can't do
that to me Jimmy
your crucify me you can't get away with
it it's conspiracy that's what it is
I'll report you to responses I know them
personally are fortunate communications
of the Guardian thing I'll break the
watch anyway now look mrs. Kovach if
there's anything I can do you oh that's
Terry nice if you got off my line and
they say don't say
my dear that stinks see how he live it
really to poison me every instant I have
endangerment like it's an excellent god
man okay
bring us two blankets two pair
cigarettes nuts
excuse me Elizabeth please listen to me
Alan's life it's it's Alan its Alan sir
it's you don't want to see that judge
again you know he might be real angry if
he found out why you took me and then we
would be able to spend they can Odin
oh wait Lee sees me fly
he won't body then I'll just a question
of flying art that you're a damn bird if
you were trying to be funny
Otto cafe trying to be funny I'm just
trying to tell you this 4,000 Chinamen
of this country that might have not
gonna cue off expense up its McHugh the
hell's unhappy about getting a wife back
for crikey
can't take any chances no chances what's
all the emergency about just have a baby
in the baby's room your food is always
perfect it is not always perfect with
you gentlemen are so gala can't speak
for the others as for myself I'm a
southerner by AXA you Thomas ticket my
collar
oh we can still save it right
shut up the DPA yeah yes I mean we've
got a story we've got no space for it
yes but will you go home please
oh I stink of my own minute cupcake why
don't you send her away for a while on
sort of a vacation to Algiers or
somewhere now you listen to this both of
you and get this thing straight just
because my mother takes it yeah Jenna
sorry what was the denomination of that
nothing I'm gonna go back to your Irina
cooking party I happen it Oh
say what's ailing you I'll bet you 20
bucks that I catch Billy before Gilbert
does good 20 bucks ice cream yeah yeah
beat that like you just learned a week
ago how to use a 19-4 huh now listen
torchy even if I agree with what you
want admitting you're a pretty good
detective and all right
what could you do that the Secret
Service men can yes
listen you do that again you rotate the
Cavs job dammit
alright pick up but we're picking it up
again when the cute little of my second
judge hands me my detail what kind of a
phony is this he says our divorce isn't
oh yeah
I'll save you the trouble see you
cashier and get this out Oh see the
cashier and get yourself I don't want
anything but these gentlemen do they
want you on a little charge of
kidnapping and our friend Bill Clifton
would like to discuss a long line of the
right answer Johnny you know it's always
smart to have the right answers like
that you take it easy I got this thing
all figured out
god damn it can you pick it up shut up
the big man did he did yeah mr. Brennan
yes I'm gonna kick the hello good
morning miss Han I was wondering if I
might speak to mr. have mr. Han I fine
doctor mr. house mr. muoi heaven on a
good it good what about you Rick
I don't believe you even consulted him
they wouldn't [ __ ] about evidence in
the murder case if they didn't think
they had enough evidence they go to it
god dammit let's figure it out no but
there's something about the way you ride
that puts my heart in my mouth oh I'm
very sorry I burned my good oh no oh god
burn myself how can we find out what can
we do
hmm buddy give that to me huh but you
won't do anything foolish I'm sorry God
all right pick of that yeah but while I
do - sit up McTavish what do i do then
captain with cabbage ready oh yeah but
what do I do when I want to see captain
McTavish yeah while I took a while up
what I can't stand it I tell you I feel
like taking his place and waiting rest
Rima hunt used to shock shock into
Kingdom damn
go ahead here we go I should heaven
don't worry is camera that's what I'm
not can you see was there starting I'm
sorry oh honey here we go
in fact oh sorry yes halibut some of it
later they're done why even the woman
you went to after you committed the
murder she'll go against you she'll say
that sacrifice yourself to save set
sacrifice somebody up alright I say that
Felix these two men of the hundred a
month to live here you girls would screw
Oh
Shama Bonita a sauna believe it son a
[ __ ] their gun okay you thought I was
gonna say Ashley a son of a [ __ ]
no Peter
remember what Confucius say washing for
offering my crown nopperz obstacle any
oven
there goes a little pun
Oh Bobby this is no time for jerk Oh
jerky you think that but you don't know
come on Stacy make a statement you
haven't got a chance
why you dirty hey just a minute this is
supposed to be my dance
what are you doing here
Oh
thank you very much governor oh boy did
I blow that back thank you very much
quiet underwire Lucas happy we have
filmed it in natural color
and it will do a great oh boy need any
training either I know I know but then
again look you got me wrong mister thank
Emily thank you sir Oh mio don't want to
news turn a few bucks I'll be on my way
you're on your way right now
but I told you I'm broke I counted on a
few weeks salary here you can stop gum
now there's a boat leaving for the
state's tomorrow night son of a [ __ ]
ship it but this cigar have swallowed
eighteen-month oh my god Thomas right
now that's right the valiant doesn't
taste of death but 1% goddamn thing like
that what's going on here it's a swindle
the whole pays the swindle you just
tried to get rid of a ginger that's
right all three the men did and one of
them deliberately took an awful socket
pill man anybody got a bright red
lipstick mine's grown anemic here make
yourself beautiful for Eddie oh I didn't
think of it I can't think of anything
else either
who was it I don't know you mean you
don't know well I've seen morale seen up
around where Jesus
lunch one hour just what you asked for
Alma get caboose a beam at non from wha
Oh ah who's it
oh Jesus Christ Oh shall I introduce you
to my friend my wife or that god damn
tractor kielbasa no don't put them in
there put them with a 70 [ __ ] oh Jesus
oh no no no that's terrible terrible
it was great fun making the picture but
he'd be still greater front front I'm
all right
a girl in here on our shoplifting beef
is going to escape with me why don't you
make it a general food why don't you
make it a general jail delivery then
you'll really have something oh why the
hell can I think of a goddamn lunch
boy this gonna be a tough one but we'll
meet again now right you from wherever I
find big cat again [ __ ] head second
jump three feet in the air and come down
instead of the board me I'll still be in
the goddamn thing Jam goodnight love
where this moon is the no romance in
your ass the goddamned I can never think
of that god damn
what's your saying [ __ ] I don't
remember my lines
the point is dr. which do you favor
spending the cash for the new vestry of
the Cathedral or a new wing at the
hospital neither I'd spend it for I'd
spend it
buying a new studio for all another fine
fine very fine that's fine if I only
knew the line now how beautifully we
could play this scene wait a minute
perhaps you can give me some advice I'm
super cores are supposed to go all
notable OAB oh yeah if you will leave
but do you think you can if you or did
you not write me a belly which I pay you
for three times in Paris too much that's
lousy an order of transfer from the
senior officer present afloat I'm god
damned if I know why steal that'll hold
for a while I've started death don't we
uh how will you deal is your your too
conventional
good I'm all true
the world premiere of Dodge City will be
definitely held in your town oh jeez
wrong again I can't get up it now more
20 years later with every power arming
to the teeth for preparing for god
dammit it's do or die for good old
metropolis hi you you dumb [ __ ] you
tella Oh coach thanks very much miss and
don't try to use that phone again are
you know I didn't bring any costumes
with me but Bobby got the independent
alone why this gonna be a tough one to
all the front don't try and fool me I'm
but then I didn't know I didn't know
that heaven was a little spot in
Honolulu oh good god but it stinks
welcome home at the bay hello what sin'
yes sir the show good news in that
telegram you censor and it said that it
is you're worried about welcome home
little bay hello Watson yesterday sure
welcome home mr. May hello What's in
into the show good news in that telegram
to and because you wanted to get those
chicks you thought if I would pay $1000
cash now for them that you could get a
whole lot out in earth goose I preferred
that it wasn't the reason it we're just
a climax or one walk and they got god
damn you are very clever madam
you have very clever madam I'm very
happy
but the greatest common with that oh I
blew it good the great
thank you oh yeah who the hell put this
leg right over there you guys
dang it I don't know whether you care or
not but my granddaughter's in jail for a
crime she didn't commit now you tried to
sell those checks ah
come on come on simulate firing as soon
as you hit the line oh they're gotta
find son of a [ __ ] hey you tried the
cookie slim but well what'd I tell you
she's a hell of a wife that them I don't
believe you yet you old-fashioned pizza
really oh yeah just what I've been
looking for missile swenerton mrs.
Swinton oh you son of a [ __ ] Oh Adil
you are so somber in your black coat why
do you not wear your gear why's your
party rusty oh I beg you
and here he is folks that red-blooded
red-faced redheaded ki man to the West
the mightiest horse tamer in captivity
whale smoke oh boy looks like our luck
still home I still can't face my ass off
the ground
what Davy little two males you have my
dear what do we got to lose you don't
have to go back to the States
there's an iron gate behind mmm damn it
mean discussing why don't you draw us an
English American or some goddamn vain to
your father you can't speak to that I'm
not a battle pass why you my god
we're damn it I'll be goggle you dirty
son
well well fancy meeting you again
now whatever coming nice I said what are
you waiting on oh my friend you do all
this for me
oh you are my brother my sister my
mother my grandmother my grandfather oh
I beg your pardon
no oh why do I have that hand in my
pocket all the time
is that all you want to go on a
honeymoon for and get married for just
go you can hang around an old plane well
there isn't gonna be any wedding or any
New York or any honeymoon or anything
else you just made up aluminum and
scored cylinders an old worn-out spark
plug you haven't got any more romance
imagine that old pair of pliers it'd be
too bad if those eggs were fertile this
guy's loudly wake up Easter morning and
discover he's a mother open your mouth
oh right after the scene was shot 458
Hollywood chicks organized the screen
layers guild Colonel Forbes William
lovely yeah wait
don't put your hair back very much don't
put your hair back now water fire I
gotta see if you don't mind don't pull
your hair back but get her across the
stage and applied some confident manner
if they write anything but oh Christ
late what do I have to do tell you
things in six different languages sorry
you're sorry
look at my hat I don't know what the
hell to say you turn left do you turn
left that dezik uh dammit I said it Man
Overboard
Oh this was a fire I know just what to
do well I bet it's even 30 years and I
can't swim a stroke
beautiful Eddie what's matter with her
Bullitt County dad no you can't leave
her here like this you've got to stay
here like a more to the jam is that a
dimension still good in stock it's
sentimental they call you lose weight
years like think of the lines that maybe
I'll see the guy that bullet got her hmm
dad no no we can't leave her here like
this can you leave me here like this cuz
I don't own the gun what are you pulling
now
no that's Santa's Daniels no one that
she trip if you try to jump the boat
well it got a forest I can't say it
mm-hmm you know Daniels that fella did
she trip when she tried to jump the boat
well he's got a for his supper than his
head I tried to say a bit more
howdy plaster hi Alvin I've been kind of
expecting to see you yeah yeah
I'm right toys please sure some accent I
got three women and one she is having a
whole past full of women Wow better
marry her be a bigamist she big bus ha
ha yes sir Beavis just cuz I mean god
damn to finally draw whoa
I had a pair of crutches made for cookie
last thing you did was hit me on the
head with them not going to dr. L I am
sorry you're promoted you know I bet you
think nothing now turning that knife on
me if you would stifle dammit
from the first moment that my brothers
both sided us we made it all up
no I could walk he didn't tell you any
of that titty no what do you mean to him
what a hill your eyes me to him he
doesn't care about your eyes you're not
bending his nuts
of course I know your capacity for that
she's devastated not so devastated she
lost his sense of direction she made
straight for the library that's all
right at the Perot library she can make
for it if she likes I hear your
collaboration when I can't work around
here
oh you're following me all I can know
that
are you going to tell dr. stork keep
that clown happy - like god damn son of
a [ __ ] he's been home for two weeks
they're fine how-do-you-do to get
smacked in the kid - with the minute I
turned my god dammit the minute I turned
my back all right then catch Christ I'm
sorry Morris but Sandra just told me
that I was only nuts to that goddamn
line I can't remember it but I didn't
die and I haven't stayed away and I want
that child you're not going to have it
examine up there's millions of people
all of you here for instance who don't
lots more than I have
just doing the daily jobs god damn it
I'm on a kite so man so part sort of one
around the snow black took him in and
then the dead man Dan up and die with
the Pomona
so part here well this blessed time on
last one a snow slide come down boom on
that man's house and kill him dead but
didn't kill part two so well so dead
with it later
yeah oh say cliff I just happen to think
if you're planning on getting married or
anything
all those row eggs will come in handy
you're doing always just suffered
and here he is folks that red-blooded
breath face redheaded ki mana the West
the mightiest horse tamer in captivity
well smoke oh boy looks like our luck
still hold
I still can't face my ass off the ground
this will give you just a rough idea of
a director instructing his cast how to
play a scene
mr. Charles Boyer at the piano and mr.
cooling the director taking the place of
Joan Fontaine who was watching mr.
Golding off seeing mr. guling evidently
was not at all satisfied with his
reversal soul he will endeavor to get
into character by wearing miss
Fontaine's hat and play up to mr. Bowie
all right head he give our source doctor
a gun from the forest
one two three four
and now what the movie public demands a
real $0.55 love scene I say that was a
scorcher
you always act so funny Leslie you're
gorgeous shot it give us another
I say that was a scorcher you always act
so funny Leslie you're gorgeous shot it
give me another
I say that was a scorcher you always act
so funny Leslie you're gorgeous
Charlotte
give us another I say that was a
scorcher are you always so funny Leslie
oh you're gorgeous Charlotte
give us another I say that was a
scorcher you always act so funny Leslie
you're a gorgeous Charlotte come on give
us another
poor Annie she has to do this
you see she took some medicine and
forgot to shake the bottle and if the
case isn't settled by then I'm going to
give the estate away to the Salvation
Army and I knew god damn well I'm just
going to say I'm through this thing
through me what is it
here he is coppered Dennis Daniel O'Hara
alias red please guilty of crap Annie hi
oh yes my darling
a thousand times yes and if he doesn't
cut I don't know what my hell I'm good
oh that must be bird now I told him to
meet me here
god damn match
stinks
just put in a medal on you for getting
me fired if you'd kept your bustle
inside this Juke I might have a chance
to bring to see bro now what's your news
oh I got a letter from dread para god
damn Drake dear Drake glad to hear that
you're feeling good and everything's
going so well I always skip that
of course I'm good Oh Paris Jesus Christ
sorry
I suppose it's pretty big field sir
maybe too big maybe a hundred years off
of course you could never tell
hey I'm not talking the dialogue from
kasi was poisoned then quite a bit later
doctor tower shot himself he had been
dead very long when the cook came in had
found him and I forgot the rest of the
line from there but it'd be great if I
remember it very lucky but I didn't have
any to do with the murderer
whatever you caught god damn it
I just haven't remember bently he flew
one over there and never came up never
came back never showed up the Sun its
drowned
what's caught your eye Humphrey oh I can
see why you're having trouble keeping
your eyes focused too much for you poor
fella you just rest quietly uh well the
return of the man who came to dinner and
the laws of the state of California left
[ __ ] therefore who God hath joined
together let no man put asunder
I think he got damn Gooden for somebody
where they have mister I had fused God
for being a racketeer and I wanted
brought to trial with that close to it
fine and now he wants $190 because he
knows that's what we've got saved up mr.
Johnson and I have been saving for a
long time no yeah and now he wants $190
because he knows that's what we've got
saved up mr. Johnson and I have been
saving for a long time to buy a boat
with tube how is that one you've got
there
all right March the ground quarters
ground quarters what the hell is ground
quarters yeah god I nearly cut my throat
Alissa right then take a ride
making a future with her kids that
somebody can't buy missed oh Christ
yeah good all right 25 years past
he keeps prophetic rodent assault
do you hear man with me the silicon wait
over that yes 13 god dammit I see her
get out a new thing you set up you and
me Danny since when do we get to be such
fun
oh boy I'm sorry about that out there
with Kylie he's he's getting too big for
his britches
that's the problem with Kelly he's
getting too big for his britches he's
getting too big for his britches I look
at the wrong side of camera
no honey doctor I can't help but it's
orders I don't tell you her name uh her
name what the hell is our night oh we're
subject to your approval dr. dog doesn't
eat dog Oh huh not a practicing
physician now what the hell oh I say if
ever there was a stupid 14-karat dumb
cluck what I have is owned and examined
that's me do you believe me now
I'll be god damned if I know what the
hell is say she give me oxygen
she's cried like a hell of a time now we
are boys hacen all come on left it all
right your dive keeper how do you think
for a second that we gonna come in this
crummy cop's damn place against ego
which me listen I has this Osterman
would you feel about her you thought it
was all over but it wasn't still there I
could
god damn it still in you Father
okay what all remember the sad the iTune
doing up something to break away the
broadcast
say something is Achille say something
cut Maggie you know that one of my
cardinal principles is never to
interfere in anybody else's wife don't
look at me and say
yes I arrived in white tie and Tails to
be met by two big wheat buffers who very
quietly proceeded to take my trousers
off I was then assured in my lemon
yellow shorts god dammit
have you ever met our friend Shelly my
own if you really must know the truth
and I bloody well gone again on the same
god damn life
but Shelly darling I've been so worried
now seeing you on this chair this chair
fits my fanny as nothing else ever hands
who would have thought an hour ago I'd
be on my way to South Carolina life is
just full of surprises will you both
stop this violent headache shall I tell
you how little through the South Seas
like a silver scimitar or would you
rather hear how I finished a three-act
play with one hand whilst making love to
a Maharajah with
sorry yes I had your hat that's alright
I had yours well then I must have yours
then you've got mine say we girls
certainly have trouble with our hats you
give me mine or I'll hit you with my
beaded bag mr. Flynn was always one for
exercise you got those big shoulders
playing tennis his big arms from golf
his big chest from swimming and you
ought to see his great big but can you
blame a fella thie likes to ride
horseback
well mr. Flynn seems to be making eyes
at someone
what Errol gets this look in his eye
look out girls it only means one thing
and oh boy look at the little nubber
he's promised to screen test this time
careful my little pigeon there's a
Seahawk after you mr. Flynn's in a bad
way but he claims these eyes are helpful
when he eats in a restaurant with one
eye he can watch his dinner well the
other watches his hat and coat the
glamour boy in action
Oh Errol you kiss so divinely oh I used
to be a Boy Scout bugler I still can't
face my ass off the ground
all right now take a deep breath and
hold it
I'll try not to hurt I'll try to get the
goddamn dresser I want to see hot Papa
please I want to see how life turn apart
please mrs. Kennard don't get yourself
excited I know you have a great
emotional distress but let's try to be
reasonable by going to the police what
will you gain not for well most of you
guys just mess it up I thought perhaps
you were did you find out that you were
free tonight
that's the wrong goddamn why haven't I
said my name was Rex Durant well for a
pineco uh right here you know I never
drink on an empty stomach
get me something to eat by John no no no
no no not that ridiculous thing nice is
some caviar listen here as it decently
chilled
Oh LS lettuce what a large piece i
goodness just imagine ten million people
listening at one time what a colossal
invention in miniature our poor Oh a
letter came this morning
Michael climbing god damn say where it
is all right now take a deep breath and
hold it I'll try not to hurt I'll try to
get the goddamn dress off
no no make it age will you ate at my
hotel lovely to talk to you uh goodbye
now there there is an object lesson in
how not to ask for the man seemed to
have spilt your drink let me parties
but smug take a deep breath and hold it
I'll try not to hurt too much can we do
it over yes look again crash what are
you doing here practicing my
broken-field running Oh drink no thanks
oh hey you know I haven't been in an
apartment like this for a long time it's
been two years since I was in New York
how does it look to you not the same as
any other place these days but good
you're looking blooming oh I'm fine
you've been getting any lately overtime
you mean this is a deplorable situation
and something's got to be done about it
I'm not gonna stand idly by ad can't you
understand that I that I don't want to
go to the dance
oh I know you're trying to be a good
sport about it but I'm going to get to
dad I take a deep breath and hold it
I'll try not to hurt too much
did you notice anymore blonde wife Regan
was supposed to run off with who doesn't
did you know that anymore zone the gun
god dammit K must be difficult for a man
who has spent a lifetime stirring of us
sir sir god damn and knowledge that they
didn't Tanner come at your invitation
and didn't you try to get rid of him
because you knew that your husband was
coming home unexpectedly
that's not true and didn't he refuse to
leave because he knew Kravis in the
gallispan dark I had another one of
those goddamn pits could I bring a
friend of mine Steve trilling along he
has fits every day hello hi Andy it was
quite a snowfoot you had last night
why will be in 10 minutes TV Thank You
Man there you're still surprised Wyoming
god damn did you juju dick all women are
gamblers Emily otherwise we'd never get
married
Oh God
all women again mr. president mr. McComb
how do you do mr. president a pleasure
indeed sir hmm
Jesus Christ Annie your handle that
cigar like a monkey handles a coconut
I beg your pardon mr. president
every time in rehearsal scenes you pull
that same trick now you know an act with
many sensitivity Lulu Haley
darling what are you Sally DISA Stanley
Blake Sally of Sally Oh your wrinkles
over all ends what the poet's call one
of those lovely things that isn't meant
to laugh one ham on get me kill goings
on Sally what's the matter you unhappy
about something
what is it is it love she said my life
yeah cut it oh you know it's two years
since I've been in New York how does it
look to you well I'm about the same as
everybody's out these days but good
you're looking blooming oh I'm fine just
fine
well I don't know whether you've laid
any leg hey you know it's none of my
goddamn garlic Moses where do you want
the remains sent is it that bad what
happened Mike see these New York women
are certainly nuts
oh hi don't thanks though Louis Christ
ha ha knocking myself out of anybody
hello Sally I want you to meet Van
Johnson presidency Actors Guild say I
meant to tell you I fixed up a little
lab on the porch I hope you don't mind
found a table I could use had to extend
the gas connection a bit for the Bunsen
burner
look I hope you don't mind we get a god
damn regret heaven that yeah why hope
you know what well all right listen
what's the deal what uh there's like it
says that oh Christ it's nothing are you
comfortable in the house very
Josephine's a fine cook I'll probably
end up getting fat I hope you don't mind
I meant to tell you that if I got the
line right I was gonna build a
laboratory in a goddamn fort
Ohman you don't know where I could find
an apartment do you why sure Joe how
about the King's Arms King's Arms
where's the Kings arms around the
Queen's ass very really yeah really
I still can't face my ass off the ground
sir Johnny Rocco was more than a king he
was an emperor his rule extended over
beer the slot machines the numbers
racket and it does another forbidden
enterprises he was a master of the fix
Jesus eyes turn on it that's right Mary
oh no you get out you turn right around
in me oh but Mary you heard me
I planned for four years how you were
gonna see me it wasn't gonna be like
this you get out in town for 20 and then
come in again all right Mary Oh John
hiya Fred God
my gosh H does my tails I get 20 years
oh well I'll take my chances with this
holy Oh God and they're already choosing
up sides for the next war who whose oh
Christ
there he comes again mr. Wilson we want
to show you with a tell attempt to ask
to head up smelvin all who profess and
close those Christians maybe lemon in
the way of truth will hold the faith in
unity and spirit then the way through
right and heat myself you don't have to
besides it's not true I'm not losing
Karen I hope you're right Sam patience
and love are synonymous and my patience
is just as great as my love you have to
have a lot of patience to read his
crappy dialog yeah and they're already
choosing up sides for the next war who
whose oh Christ
there he comes again better go tell this
market
what are they kid get out of the wood
well the goddamn thing won't work mister
fusty but let me tell your story
it's from Tolstoy it seems that a rich
man encountered a peasant working in the
fields
he was so contented with his humble job
that had made the rich man curious he
asked him what would you do if you knew
- tomorrow I'll be a son-of-a-bitch
higher why did you tell your mother why
didn't you tell your mother he was
coming home frankly I wanted God done
I'm done and they're already choosing up
sides for the next war who whose oh
Christ there he comes again
why didn't you tell you then why didn't
you tell your mother he was coming on
why didn't you tell your mother you was
coming home answer me that
thank me I wanted some time alone with
you well that's Frank enough what for me
I asked because the last time you saw
him you struck him and knocked him down
that's why the father is supposed to
strike anyone he's fine
killer all right I think I understand
that night in the church when I first
met you it was pretty obvious that Oh
shucks that you'd miss it what are you
saying Frank I believe some words words
what words they went like this but we of
the United goddamnit and they're already
choosing up sides for the next war who
whose oh Christ
there he comes again
oh you got
with only 300 odd days left in 48 New
York spinsters organized a leap year
Club and lay plans to trap their
hard-to-get animal the American bachelor
girls you're all members of a leap year
club our slogan is get a mate in 48 now
we are gathered together discuss our
plans girls how will we get all men
Madam President and fellow members I
feel that we girls have all been changed
for use by the wrong men now it's our
chance to chase the right men let's pick
out what we want and let's go after it
I suggest this attack a good car a good
job and then get him along girl we've
got to plan this operation carefully men
are no longer convenience while they're
with me oh there I locked it up okay
honey chil try it again
my girls we've got to plan this
operation carefully melon no longer
convenience by with me man just a plain
citizen let us close our meeting with
our cheer one two three dance don't you
think we'd be too crowded Oh y'all got
again oh here we go
as well
this is Froy
go to your license place we serve
I like this do you shave
oh yes sir would you like a
demonstration oh sure I myself have you
have much experience no sir you're my
first one oh sit down
mutton you're waiting oh no sir wait to
tie I'm still breathing hell here we go
pardon me my mistake
oh my what are you doing here well I see
if my insurance is in order sit down let
me finish her up I want to shave once a
day you don't mind
well might as well take a trim as long
as you're happy I'm your rounds we going
see here I wanna get the hell out of you
they all say the Brooklyn cowboy and ice
beneath them open Maxie help you throw